so look every five years some kind of a
crisis happens every ten years something
dramatic happens you go back to old one
9/11 2008 market crash 2020 coronavirus
pandemic it doesn't matter every five to
ten years a crisis takes place and
during times of crisis wartime leaders
do well today we're going to talk about
the differences between a wartime leader
and a peacetime leader all right so
before I get into let's define what is
wartime and what is peacetime wartime is
your start up the first year second year
third year you're about to go out of
business you're running out of money
every day a million different things are
hitting everything you got it's like the
end of the world peacetime is you're
working for an established company
that's a fortune 500 company that has
cash that is sitting on a lot of
reserves there's a massive team there's
a lot of decisions to be made if you
have a bad you know day you can lean on
somebody else there's a big difference
there right now between wartime and
peacetime I want to give you an example
what happened to me when I was in the
military so I'm at the hundred first
Airborne Division aresult we are invited
to this one event and a general gets up
and he talks and he gives this message
and he says you know pop up on he's
given all this message for like 20
minutes and by the time he was done I'm
watching the entire audience because I'm
a brand-new private and I just got to
this unit and I saw some people got up
and some people started clapping but it
wasn't that kind of a massive standing
up rolling for this person right so then
the next speaker came up and the next
weeka came up wasn't higher ranking than
this general and a next speaker came up
and he started talking he wasn't as good
of a speaker as the first one the first
one was fiery loud all this stuff but
the second one got up was a little bit
mild was a little bit calmer but he gave
this speech and by the time he was done
everybody got up screaming off the top
of their lungs for the second officer
that spoke so I went to my sergeant
afterwards I said hey so I'm braixen
what just happened over there that guy
is a higher ranking person there
as a low-ranking person what why why
didn't people cheer for him as much as
they did for the other person he says
that's what you don't know let me tell
you the differences between these two
leaders so what is it he said the guy
that got up he made it to the top
through doing all the right things
because he came right school and he got
the degree from the right school the
right last name all that stuff but he
never did a lot of wartime he got all
the right badges but he never went to
war he says the second guy that got up
and he spoke he's been to pretty much
every single war you can think about the
last 30 years and the people that were
screaming for him went with him because
it was a wartime leader no matter what
you ever do the first guy even a bigger
rank cannot get the kind of respect the
guy got that one in the trenches with
the rest of the people he should see the
looks on people's faces they were crying
when this guy was given a speech as if
this was like their father
it was very emotion I saw the difference
between a wartime leader and a peacetime
leader so that's the point when I'm
trying to make you what is a wartime and
a peacetime so having said that let's
get right into it
wartime leaders a bad day a bad week a
bad month can cost a lot of casualties a
peacetime leader a bad day a bad week or
a bad month won't affect them so it's
kind of like it's just another bad month
we'll make it up next month it's just
another bad quarter we'll make it up
next month these guys don't have that
kind of time so it's always going going
going because they know it's gonna cost
a lot of casualties number two people
follow wartime leaders because of their
heart because of their charisma and
because of their emotion people believe
we're going places people follow
peacetime leaders because of their
knowledge and their intelligence oh wow
she is so smart oh wow he has a right
degree oh wow he is so intelligent its
intelligence its heart we're going
places third one they communicate with
all of their troops one on one small
group settings with four or five people
and large group settings with hundreds
if not thousands of people but peacetime
leaders they communicate through people
and committees and if they're going to
give a message to you as large group
very rarely one-on-one because you know
it's like you can't
come talk to me have you gone through
your levels here what's going on tell me
what's gonna I want to get to know even
in the book linking our leadership in
the book he talks about circulate
amongst your troops one of the strengths
Lincoln had is he would go out there and
circulate amongst his troops to find out
what's going on soldiers had no idea
they're also walking us up what way the
president is here I'm a private
so tell me private Johnson how are
things going oh my gosh
Oh President Lincoln is like no don't
worry about it so tell me what's going
on are you kidding me
that's what you call a wartime that's
why Lincoln is considered one of the
greatest presidents of all time next one
quick decisions they threw a leader
meaning about what's gonna so what do we
know about okay here's what we're gonna
let's go boom quick decisions on this
side
methodical decisions through committee
if you've ever seen a movie Ford versus
Ferrari and you know that scene when
Shelby comes up and he sits down is like
watching the photo goes from this person
to that person to this person to that
person and he's sitting in there says
why did we lose you embarrass me and
bebe is sitting sitting back there and
he says if you if I can be frank with
you I can tell you something here you
wasted four P I watch for people go
through the folder to loot or until it
came into your hands if you're gonna let
me do this you gotta give me all
authority for me to do this and then
boom they want to work and obviously
know how the story ends committees Ford
individual Tesla remembers like the best
example I can give you right there
here's what we're going to be doing let
me talk to 74 different people before we
make this decision
next one they're comfortable breaking
things as long as progress is being made
wartime leaders they're famous for
breaking things they're going to break
things but they're gonna make progress
peacetime leaders they're very wary
about breaking things so the decisions
are a little bit more about perfection
what can we do to make the perfect
decision progress perfection progress
perfection so now you're watching is it
what path should we can can i go out and
work with a wartime or peacetime if your
work in a start-up environment and
you're there when the company is about
to go out of business every day and they
make it somebody and there was a wartime
leader if there has to be a wartime
leader somehow somebody had to know that
they can handle the decisions momentous
decisions here's what we're going to be
doing if you work for
larger corporation and you always trying
to get done and you have to wait three
minutes six a three months six months
for a decision to be man your piece time
I got a call from an old colleague of
mine and I was in Detroit when he called
me we're on the phone together and he's
expressing his frustration okay
and he says Pat here's the difference
between you and I you're an entrepreneur
I'm not I can't make the decisions like
you guys are making we're part of a big
company we have this and we have that we
can't make it takes six months if you
wanted to do something you make the
decision like this because he's working
here with a peacetime a type of an
environment over here is a wartime type
of an environment so for you somebody
may say well Pat I don't know if I can
work with a wartime I'd might try to
work with a peacetime okay no problem so
a couple things to identify with that
when does it make sense to work with a
wartime one does it make sense to work
with a peacetime if you're in the face
of playing offense and coming up this is
what you want if you're in the face of
you no longer want crazy crazy pressure
you want stability I will never forget
the day we started our own insurance
company I held a meeting on Tuesday
night it wants a four o'clock the
following day I held a meeting on
Wednesday night September 24th of oh
nine if you look up the calendar I think
the 24th falls on a Wednesday so either
Wednesday or Thursday I think so
Wednesday I hold a meeting when I'm
holding a meeting I get up and I say
here's what we're doing we're getting
ready to start a company and this is
what's gonna take place there's a 90%
chance we're gonna go out of business
90 per this is recorded by the way 90%
90% chance I don't have as much money as
other companies my saving is in this my
saving isn't that I don't have that they
have four hundred billion dollars we
don't have any of that stuff there's a
90% chance I want to be sued there's a
90% chance I want to put out of business
there's a 90 I'm given all this stuff so
then I stopped and I said if you want
safety and you above a certain age where
you cannot take risks I suggest you
don't come with me because there's a 90%
chance I'm gonna go out of business if
you want safety here's where to go if
you want risk you come with me what do
you want to do one lady gets up we'll
never forget it till today her name is
Sharon and she was one of the most
honest people we had she got up and she
said I just have to be honest
with the m61 I can't afford that I love
you I would love to I just can't do
it because if you go I can't afford that
kind of stuff I said I have nothing but
respect
I wrote the numbers down of people I
said call this person she called the
person fast over two years later that
wolf came back the person I gave it a
number to and hurt they ended up working
with us two years later but at that time
I gave the options right some people
cannot afford to work with a wartime
some people want to work with a large
companies that if you're 59 years old
you're kinda like I don't know if I can
take that kind of risk I want to work
somewhere that's a lot safer I get it
but the moral of the story is this today
when you're watching this we have a
pandemic going on coronavirus people are
afraid Cobin xix everybody shakin
everybody's nervous every spine is
looking to see what to do
this model during times like this fails
miserably these are the times that you
go here these are the times where exes
call their ex-boyfriends and they call
them because they have more trust in
that person's confidence to know that
they break confidence during time like
this because they say should I worry is
everything gonna be okay what what why
are you calling your ex boss why are you
calling because that person was a
wartime leader because that person
doesn't lose cool during times like this
they go calm poised and they give you
confidence remember your people will
feel your fear your people would feel
your confidence not through statements
not through talks through a video like
this I'm talking to you're doing a zoom
people are looking at you're saying he
is afraid or he's not afraid
I feel the guys confidence I feel her
confidence man she looks nervous did you
see the lip did you see the voice it's
cracking a little bit she's nervous
everybody when you're a leader is
watching to see if you're here or if
you're here during times of crisis now
let's address the other point here is it
easier for peacetime to be a wartime or
is it easier for wartime to be a
peacetime keep this in mind peacetime
leaders typically want to do the process
of they went to the right schools they
did the right thing then when it got a
nice degree Columbia Yale Harvard
Wharton stamp
you know the right way of going through
it right so everything's been kind of
planned have been kind of known what
they're gonna be doing since they were
14 years old I'm gonna go to this school
I'm gonna go get this degree then I'm
gonna get my MBA and then I'm gonna go
work for this company and I'm gonna be
this these guys on the other hand man
challenge and Families dad told them you
will never amount to anything Elon Musk
yeah you ain't nobody gonna come back to
the country there's no way in the world
you're gonna make it in America you're a
fool to think you're gonna make it in
America you're out of your mind you know
mom gives you up for adoption she
couldn't handle having you because she
couldn't afford the finances not because
she didn't love you but the day you were
born she gave you up to adoption and
that's stuck with your name is Steve
Jobs I'm telling my stories like that
you go through it you're like you know
what screw this whole thing i'ma prove
appointed a world that's wartime wartime
wartime eventually is forced to learn
how to be peacetime because they have to
they have to they have no control
because when there is no war they have
to or else Apple will fire you and then
you have to go start Pixar and then you
come back because you were a wartime
leader you did not know how to be a
peacetime leader then when you come back
around after pink Pixar then you're a
peacetime leader and a wartime leader
because you've never learned you matured
Steve Jobs you got to learn that part
right so this person will be forced to
learn how to be like this but very
rarely will a peacetime leader be put in
a situation to be like this because it's
scary it's easier for them to learn how
to be like this than for them to learn
how to be wartime because some of it is
life experiences how do you teach a kid
that grew up on the streets who's a UFC
fighter but he didn't become a UFC
fighter because you know their parents
were good money makers and they say I
want you go take an MMA class so why
don't you go take some mixed martial
arts no the kid that fights in MMA who
grew up in the streets in Boston and he
was fighting since he was four years old
or his Irish he grew up in streets with
nothing and you had to fight everybody
that guys been beat up since he was four
or five six years old he's
on how to stand up for himself he
doesn't have the little fears that
somebody else is going to have that
bidding going to the street fighting
these guys were street fighting
regularly very hard to teach that so
these guys can go here these guys can go
here the best situation is when they
work together Badou if they can find a
way to team up it's by far the best
situation and by the way they're you
know each other
but deep down inside they know they need
each other if you get a situation like
this where these two guys team up that's
money right there that's like the way to
do it and last but not least remember
over here they're the favorites they're
the underdogs I don't know why wartime
leaders are always the types of
underdogs Churchill was an underdog man
they just wait till you see what we're
gonna are you kidding me you are not
gonna do nothing to Britain because do
you know it's the underdog or they're
under estimating me that's the underdog
mentality of wartime these guys have
always been the guy that's supposed to
be who he's supposed to be or she's
supposed to be very big difference so
look the reason why the board all of a
sudden disappeared is because we haven't
done a shirt in a long time and I said
what if we could get a shirt that says
wartime leader on it we did not know if
we were gonna get a done by now but
Mario was able to pull some strings we
were able to get these two shirts for
you and we got them in two different
colors one is in green it says wartime a
leader with the value tamer logo there
for you to represent the other one is in
black and white
I like black and why do you have the
choice of either green or black you like
to sport out there saying you're a
wartime leader I guarantee you you're
gonna be the only one wearing a shirt
that says wartime leader and you will
run into other value tenders because
they recognize the local and they're not
gonna see this content anywhere else
so if you like to get one of these your
two things you got to do one either send
us a text or three one zero three four
zero one one three two and text the word
leader three one zero three four zero
one one three two text the word leader
you'll get the link to order the shirts
or if you're outside of the United
States go on the link below in the
description it'll take you straight to
the site order the shirt order your size
extra large double XL medium small
whatever maybe green red green black for
yourself or your friends for your
teammates whoever it is maybe even get
it as a gift for some other that you see
as a wartime leader this is your
opportunity to do so and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
[Music]